how much credibility does john bolton
have today aside from the fact that you
know anytime he's willing to trash trump
you know the media wants to bring him on
but when you make a comment like this
what does the average person think when
they read this how much credibility do
you give this guy when somebody like him
writes that
putin's 30 or 100 year war for ukraine
like that's what we got to do who's
going to buy into that by the way can
you pull up the new york times article
you know when when he says you know
putin's popularity is increasing you're
thinking well how do we know that
uh uh go to the one i just texted you i
said is this the one facebook no go to
is this the one or no
face with pressure uh uh is this the one
yeah look at that one go a little lower
look what its popularity is if you go a
little lower
okay second paragraph eighty-three
percent of russians said they approve of
mr putin's actions up from 69 percent in
january according to a poll by
lavada center an independent pollster in
moscow ratings of many other government
institutions as well as governing party
have also gone up this is being written
by the most liberal paper
in america to say 83 percent like if
there's anything that would need to
write a propaganda would be the fact
that even the russian people don't agree
with their leader which is putin
so
and it is one of the most pro-biden uh
papers in america as well yeah far far
left i mean supporting anything that's
uh
you know
wall street journal would be in the
middle these maybe center right these
guys are far left
why why are the russian people so
supportive of him
why are the russian people so supportive
of him and at the same time if this
guy's at 83 percent you know well
biden's right now 39 percent
why are the russian people so supportive
of them why are so many american people
not supportive biden
well let me go to answer your john
bolton question first i didn't want to
just pass by that well who would take
john bolton seriously
you know most people in washington would
the establishment republicans would uh
you know the people who didn't like a
lot of them who didn't like trump even
those who did support trump i
i ha i have long been a uh
an admirer of john bolton although i
disagree with him on a lot of things
yeah uh you know uh he he had he does
have a a keen analytical mind you know
uh
you know he he has uh deep jew strategic
insights into into matters uh which is
why despite his combative
personality
all right that has uh that often gets
him in trouble in positions that he's
held uh held in government that he has
been respected with uh hel held you know
high posts like that so there are a lot
of people that would take and should
take john bolton uh seriously uh now i
uh
i am i am more of a trump fan than i am
of a a bolton supporter and i
fundamentally disagree with bolton on a
lot of things i think his uh his
analysis for example his recommendations
his prescription for
ukraine doesn't flow logically from his
own analysis
i mean i find it
impossible to imagine i mean i think
it's a certainty that if we had tried to
engage in a war for ukraine for 30 to
100 years that we would lose
you know nato and the united states
don't have the political will or we
don't have national interests invested
in ukraine that are so serious that we
would be willing to fight with russia
for 30 to 100 years to prevail so uh but
nonetheless that's what he wants us to
do
um uh we didn't have the political will
to impose our our
the outcome on afghanistan that we
wanted against the taliban you know who
are not nearly as formidable and
adversary as uh
as the russians are so you know there's
a disconnect here i i often see between
a lot of what
uh you know bolton argues he would
answer me back by saying
in in this article he says we have to
prevail in ukraine
because
because ukraine is poland in 1939
and uh and if we don't prevail you know
there's gonna be a world war three that
this is gonna have uh in fact he does
say this in the article that the
reverberations of any kind of a russian
victory in ukraine are going to be so
profound that china and north korea and
iran and russia itself will be
encouraged to continue aggression and
we're going to find ourselves in world
war iii so this is our polish 1939
moment
we've got to step up we've got to stop
him for achieving victory and i say to
that this is not the time and place we
can win
if you don't want that a world war iii
don't go into some situation we're
almost guaranteed to lose
you know we're guaranteed to lose at a
conventional level because we can't
fight a 30 to 100 years war and russia
is not going to fight for a third 100
years they're going to use emp cyber
nuclear you know to quickly win the war
and we're not prepared for any of that
you know we need time to rebuild to
really build
and modernize our nuclear deterrent we
need time to build our general purpose
forces so that we can prevail in a world
war iii if that becomes necessary and we
most especially need time to find
competent political and military
leadership can you imagine joe biden and
general miley leading us into a world
war iii we're going to lose just based
on the leadership the terrible
leadership we we have now we we nee we
need competent political military
leadership so that we can
so that we can prevail so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]